[Musique]
donc cet après midi c'est la première
fois que je tourne à skyrock dans les
locaux de skyrock et du coup je vais
tourner mon arrivée dans les studios
après le cristal de téléphone c'était
c'était génial estime ce tournage chez
skyrock on a été hyper bien accueilli
c'est d'autant plus qu'ils font que qui
avait très envie qu'on tourne chez eux
aussi c'était assez fou parce que tout
le monde avait envie de montrer de quoi
il est capable et en tant que rappeur et
en tant qu'animateur donc on a eu un
frère de ce call qui était le parfait
chef d'orchestre des scènes qu'on
tournait dans ce plat naîtra propres
rôles de composition le mien voilà en
effet c'était top
on était sûr bon moi j'ai connu les
les ambiances de justement de planète
rap de skyrock
il ya plein de monde j'ai retrouvé la
même les mêmes ambiances un peu familier
je reste un peu l'ambiance quartier on
est tous ensemble ça rigole ça va
enfumer ses abus vesa déconner c'est un
super super super mon essai tout avec un
premier coup de fil qui ne viennent pas
alors au fret je suis à l'antenne la
dent direct comment tu t'appelles
je m'appelle clément en tant que rappeur
moi j'aime bien skyrock
forcément ça en présente un certain
accomplissement pour un rappeur petit
navire est fatigué je crois que tu te
fais trop vieux n'oublie pas d'être très
sympa là ce qui va marquer la rupture de
contrat
tu voulu répondre n'hésite pas si vous
répondez clément connais c'est le rap
game c'est ça que j'aime dans deux
émissions je te montre c'est c'est super
intéressant à jouer
mais un autre temps c'est complexe parce
que justement il faut passer juste le
monde un monde est super à l'aise sellas
tetteh à redire c'est la lumière sont
sur toi à un mec qui arrive est
justement le temps tu t'en sors
nationale où tu ne comprends pas ce qui
se passe mais en même temps énervé mais
en même temps je te sent menacé et en
fait il ya tout ça a joué
[Musique]
seulement au moment où il rentre où il
rentre dans les studios de skyrock
finalement et qui rencontrent ma star il
est comme un gamin je veux jouer ça le
gars qui a impressionné parce qu'ils
voient ce rappeur préféré me taper gêné
parce qu'il veut envoyer des punchline
en pleine tronche et en même temps il a
envie de bien faire donc il est aussi
concentrée sur ce qui doit rappeler
c'est assez complexe mais ces colis et
réalise pas qu'en fait ce qu'il vient
faire ce n'est pas juste un moyen
d'ouvrir la porte
ça a été aussi perçue comme une attaque
personnelle on sort si quelqu'un qui
connaît la musique surtout quand ils
voient freestyle et à skyrock et il ya
ce visage vous détresse en mode qu'est
ce qui se passe en fait parce qu'il sait
qu'il est mon et c'est ça qui va faire
qu'il va emmener tout ce truc de 2,2 de
deux rivales et tente de ce qu'il
fallait à ce moment là c'était montrer
aux spectateurs que ce mec-là qui est
deux minutes avant de la weed va être un
phénomène et va être le héros de cette
série est un événement qui se passait il
faut que tu incarnes
on avait conscience pendant qu'on
tournait que c'était fort qu'il était
habité et qu'il était habité par apache
et pas par atik ce jour là il fait
quelque chose qui est essentiel pour la
série voilà c'est un acteur ce jour là
c'est un acteur qui rappe mais qui ira
par un personnage qui rappelle lui quoi
[Musique]
la lutte est une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal